hey guys welcome back to your random
video we're back on monster on a roll
again and today we're gonna be talking
about how to defeat are tempered Kirin
he is the newest event quest that came
out and like I said it's our
contemporary Kirin so he's a lot
stronger than the other two versions of
Kirin but with that being said like the
V if you do enjoy us discography new I
covered the solo guts for most of the
monsters I'm also going to be doing one
like I said for Kirin which is today's
video and then a couple weeks later vol
huzzah flow is going to be in the mix
for the arc tempered monster so I'm
going to be doing him as well so be on
the lookout for that but I also cover
the solo guides for the general monsters
the Elder Dragons any upcoming monster
in the game I will cover I've already
done guides like Huan Coulter Roth who
Noster all the new ones stuff like that
as well as the weekly event quest to
tell you guys which ones are the most
important how to defeat them what the
rewards are all that good stuff and tips
and guides to make everyone a better
monster armor player but with that let's
get started with the video today the
quest you're going to want to be doing
to fight rket ember Charon is a whisper
of white mane it's a HR 50 or higher
quest with a star 9 ranking and on the
bottom it shows in our contemporary
monster which is the red glow as appear
as opposed to tempered which is just a
purple low or on the monsters icon there
now that you know that ahead of time as
always let's go over the report of the
monster the loadout moveset tips and
thoughts at the end of the video and
then we'll end it there so let's get
started
so for the report his weak point is the
head / horn with his horn being the only
breakable part and fire is his most
weakest element with ice-water sleep and
blast being tied with two stars so
definitely want to use a fire weapon if
it for most of the fight for the
recommended loadout I recommend temporal
and thunder proof Mantle's and they are
a huge recommendation because of the
amount of lightning damage he does and
how much the image does since he is our
temper tanda he now and that he does
even more damage than a regular tempered
Kirin mega armor skins and mega diamond
drugs are an absolute necessity as well
as no berries for when you're hit by his
lightning to counteract the thunder
blight other than that the rest is up to
you for both this is what I strongly
recommend for this fight and what I used
for the majority of course don't forget
the obvious potions like mega max and
ancients but those like I said are ones
I strongly recommend but moving on we
have the Musa and in the first move it's
this move I like to called lightning
chains where tons of blue electricity
scatters the ground in a straight line
you can either Superman jump if you're
caught in one or simply stand perfectly
in between two of them to avoid damage
if you're close enough you can use this
time to charge gear and get some
extra hits as well next move is his
lightning strike shield I like to call
it he launches lightning in the same
five spots every time one at the top of
his head to next to his legs and then
two in the back for his hind legs there
is a small window to sit perfectly in
between them without getting hit but you
have to be almost perfect with it so I
don't really recommend it too much there
is a another variation of this move in
the move in the mode that I have to call
harden mode or in this phase what he
does that he has ten lightning strikes
as opposed to five the first five are in
the spots we mentioned and the other
five are right next to those original
lightning strikes basically meaning you
cannot sit in between them anymore and
you will be hit will get into a little
bit more of what the harden mode is
later in the video with the tips but for
the next move we have is his head thrust
this move against Kieran or tempered
Kieran is doable and really doesn't do
too much damage but against are tempered
carry and you could basically be three
shot and I had armor skin on and that's
how much damage it did as you could see
on screen when Kieran starts prancing
during the fight sprint away to avoid
this move in any direction is completely
fine dodging is not really necessary for
this move this move also does not
activate your temporal mental since it's
not a hard enough hitting attack as
shown in the clip so definitely be
careful with this move if you do have
temporal mantle on you will not go
through it next move is the lightning
strike attack where it is one
concentrated blast in one spot Kieran
will stop point downwards then point
upwards at the sky with his horn then
immediately release a lightning at a
specific point mostly in front of him
dodging if near the move or Superman
diving if you happen to be caught in the
middle and you'll dodges move entirely
if you're quick you can also land some
extra hits against him while he happens
to charge up just for that a little bit
of damage and then we last moving the
move set is another similar lightning
strike except it's super sporadic and
attacks very fast
I have to apologize though other than
Superman jumping and getting lucky I
sadly have no explanation for this move
whatsoever I haven't noticed a pattern
with it in its super random on when he
does this and all this type of stuff so
I do have to apologize for this move in
particular but of course I have the the
tutorials for the other moves in his
moveset but once that's over and you've
been arc tempered here and congrats you
will get a Kirin ticket in your rewards
which allows you to access the blossom
layered armor set which you'll see on
the screen now you only need two so
basically just beat him twice for the
armor this is a layered set so this is
just goes on your over your normal stuff
as like an appearance thing has no stat
boosts nothing like that
moving on four tips both phases he has
are normal and harden mode like I called
them previously the difference is that
an harden Mon lightning explodes where
he walks or prances by or anything he
steps on and all attacks that do not hit
his head will bounce off and just like I
mentioned before his lightning strikes
ten times instead of five on the one
move you mentioned before I'm unaware if
mind's eye are white sharpness will
negate this type of bounds off effect
but I can guarantee you that it will
block blue sharpness move so definitely
want to aim for the head most of the
time if not all the time when you're
fighting him in this hardened mode and
then once again the perfect indicator
being when he prances wrong you see
lightning strike where he steps and then
my last tip is to be careful when Karen
finishes attacking cuz him prancing will
knock you on your butt and do some
incredible damage since he is arc
tempered so like I said definitely be on
the lookout for that move even though
it's very minor it can do some decent
damage and add up to basically you
fainting and carding guys I apologize
one thing I forgot to mention while I
was editing is that I forgot that Kieran
is since he is archit Emperor has a
gamma set and I will just go over really
quickly what comes with it just so I can
give this out of the way but the gamma
horn or the gamma headpiece comes with a
level two decorations lot with blight
resistance level one and thunder attack
level three the chest piece will come
with free element ammo op level two and
two level one decorations as seen on
screen the arms come with blight
resistance level one and free element
ammo up level one as well as to level
two decorations the belt comes at
marathon runner level two and two level
one decorations and then lastly we have
the pants which comes with a level three
decoration slot blight resistance one
and thunder attack two overall this
gives lots of damage in terms of thunder
attack it's very good against people are
against monsters they don't have a lot
of thunder it gives about level five and
it's good for blight resistance and free
element ammo up if you need to have one
of those where they hit an element
weapon personally to me this does not
fit my build what if it happens to fit
your bill definitely go and check that
out while you can
any moves or strategies you have that I
missed leave them in the comment section
below for your fellow hunters to be
informed on and with that guys it's
going to be the end of the video today
hope you guys did enjoy that honestly my
personal thoughts though I do like Kirin
I kind of don't really feel like
fighting caring too much but he is cool
in terms of design and move set he's
very it's very it's a very challenging
fight and I do like challenging fights
especially a monster hunt world our
theorem was just another step above that
and I have a feeling they did it pretty
well
which they added more movesets to the
monster so that this wasn't just a
carbon copy of kiran with just a little
bit more damage I wish this did actual
different move sets similar to how Liu
master has different moves to tea Ostra
and stuff like that but either way I
can't really complain because it just
adds that layer of difficulty to the
game but that guy's like the VP did
enjoy subscribe before new I cover the
solo guides for most of the monsters in
Monster Hunter world but being the more
difficult monsters like couche oliday
aura wolf to Roth deviljho arc tempered
Kirin all that then you know the Elder
Dragons Liu nostril I have all those
guides on those harder Manzo's if you're
having trouble with those at any point
definitely go check those videos out as
well as doing the weekly event quest to
let you guys know which ones are new
what rewards they give and all that good
stuff as well as making as well as
giving tips and guides to make everybody
a better monster hunter player but with
that my two most recent videos will be
on screen if you guys want to check that
out went that guys are bigger yesterday
hopefully enjoyed the video you guys for
watching peace out